talking about fame and all this this is
kind of scary to me you were robbed at
knifepoint hmm that when did this happen
to you Harry
this was it was on Valentine's Day which
is like you know that's what you get for
being single these days yes right you
don't have it you were single and you
always just walking around walking home
from from a friend's house crying your
eyes out because you had no rest about
five minutes from home and I'm walking
up and I kind of see this group of this
group of guys they've all got like hoods
up and their face is covered in stuff
that's a bit weird
do they know what you know I'd like it
my I heard up in a big jacket on the Hat
on and everything right it's pretty cold
and and I turned my music off because I
was listening music so you walk around
with headphones on and you're listening
to music which you should not be doing
you should be aware of your surroundings
but okay go ahead I'm not gonna turn it
off you know and I'm walking up the
street and I keep kind of turning around
and the guys cross the road and I'm like
wait yeah and and then I'm walking out
and I hear like there was like gravel on
the pavement so I hear like shuffling of
feet trying to like catch up to me
so I crossed the street and then they
cross the street and I'm like how the
[ __ ] sake this was bad and then I
crossed the street again and then they
cross the street again I'm like oh [ __ ]
sake I think I'm about to get robbed so
the guy's like hey can we talk to him
for a minute and there's nobody around
so I'm like is your heart pounding yeah
yeah bit now so I'm like sure and he's
like do you smoke weed and I said now
and he goes do you want some weight
I thought no and then he was like what
have you got on you and they all kind of
gathered round me this was something
I've been a little bit pissed off about
is because I filed a police report so
then obviously it goes in the press and
everything right and they wrote that
there was only one guy so I'd like to
clarify there was more than one guy
right but in other ways your for your
for your ego I could have fought off one
guy yeah
you know so I was like I says there was
a guy with a knife I was like just one
there was a bunch of guys whose bunch of
guys 87 guys yeah you know as soon as
Harry Styles files a police report
that's the other horrible thing that's
gonna be a public thing right yeah
there's nothing is keeping that private
so he's like what have you got on you
and I'm like I don't have anything you
know they say stop [ __ ] around and
that kind of thing hmm so I have some
cash in my pocket so I said I've got
some cash so I pull out some cash
he takes it from me and then I had like
my headphone jack it's just sticking
into my pocket news oh what's that
plugged into my god say it's my phone I
was like pull out your phones I pull out
my phone and I'm thinking okay this is
really annoying but you know I'll wipe
it and get a new farm and kind of
whatever now worth fighting over
not worth fighting over and then the
guys like okay unlock you found and the
other one like pulls his shirt up and
he's got like a knife sticking in his in
his pants I was like [ __ ] and I'm kind
of thinking like do I get I just said
like I can I'm sorry I I was like man I
can't I'm not not um
and then the guys that you've got 10
seconds to unlock your phone he starts
counting down and I'm like [ __ ] am I
gonna unlock my phone why give my phone
what's to do so then I try and give him
my phone and he's like no I needs to
unlock it and I was like I can't and
then there's a little pond behind them
near where I live and I thought about
throwing it in the pond to just be like
but hey waiter others have it right yeah
but then they would have stabbed you and
and then I thought I didn't want to piss
him off right and the lights changed and
there was like two cars coming and I
just like felt an opportunity and I just
sprinted ran and they didn't chase you
well I ran into the road and I tried to
stop a car and obviously madman runs
into the road tries to get in your car
you know go away men's right don't let
me in try and get in another car don't
let me in but now I'm slightly away from
them because I'm in the street and I
think like
just burned just turned down and ran
back towards like the little village
area and there where I live so I just
kind of sprint it but usually when I'm
out walking I'm wearing like running
stuff right and this was the one morning
like corduroy Flair's and shows great
I'm gonna have to [ __ ] sprint all the
way down this hill so yeah I just sprint
it down down the thing and and I guess
because they had some cash and stuff
they just ended up turning around